Yeah.
What,
what his mind.
My dream is to make it a music. My
passion. I want to go to school for music,
so when I'm going to get my prostheses,
I'm going to be able to walk upright.
I'm going to to walk straight.
My dream is to have a home.
Pretty simple. I have a home, a job.
My dream is to be alive. Breathe, survive.
You're treated with
disrespect when a person
90% of the time.
It's given me a lot of
information and a lot of things
for when this ends because I think
differently than I did before about being
African American,
living in the United States of America.
I do not believe in the system.
It's not built for me to have esteem
about myself and everything that's already
set up in place is already
built in Meijer for you.
The hate crimes throw the
lack of proper education,
the lack of preparedness based on what
this country is supposed to provide in
this land of opportunity. I don't see
too much opportunity here in skid row.
Skid row is a place where you come.
A lot of times when you
launch or your dreams,
you come here because all the resources
are supposedly here so you could get
your life back together.
But then they are the negative elements
here on skid row that can pull you back
into that old life.
So it's hard for you to dream.
I addiction if you crack cocaine with jive
for absolutely.
Years ago now,
I began after the to 25.
It's screwed up in a heroin.
Heroin, been a heroin addict.
Blue.
I had to come up sometimes.
I uh,
my past
and
the,
I just overdosed last year. I was
in a coma for two weeks. I got out.
It took me five months to
learn how to walk again.
And I've been trying to learn how to walk,
but I again,
I can't really do it that well.
It's hard.
She naps
all kinds of substances at a control.
A lot of people here aren't in this
situation. They want to be here.
Nine g
CMIT Oh,
few people about the situation down here.
My dream is to become a pastor because
I feel like God has called me to that.
And to actually reach out to people
that have gone through what I've gone
through right now.
My dream is to help others know that
not go through the same trials and
tribulations.
I just want to make our
life so that he can grow up.
We live in our own house,
own yard on that.
We're not all beggars down
and we're not all people that,
that asking for a handout.
We're asking for help and
assistance with what we want to do.
We want to do it for ourselves,
but we can't do it without help.
People minimize
and see whether it's a
little bit different than the
shanty town. What'd you pay?
But you know some type of pain and
say, well, this person's payments
throughout this whole 50 black community,
what I see is homelessness.
Why even seen hopelessness?
But one thing that is present in every,
each and every one of us is dreams and
there's a whole lot of dreams here in
skid row.
It's important to dream dreams because
that's what wakes you up in the morning.
That's what gets you out of bed.
That's what makes you walk.
But one thing. Find the other
end, aspire to get anywhere. Um,
faith. Hope. That's the only thing
that keeps me going. Sometimes that's,
that's my fuel. And the only thing
I'm running on half the time.
And that's why the dreams
and the people here,
so what people can do
is listen to our voice is
two sides to every story.
Just hear both sides from being your
here we have fantastic.
Well,
we have the technological possibility
of making everybody on her.
The joy of an independent.
Yeah.